[Music]
so first of all thank you everyone for
one finding this a little difficult to
get here from the main area and two for
coming at the end of the day I realized
that I am the last thing between you and
starting your evening so I really
appreciate your making it here so GCP
DCP next day 1 a lot of exciting stuff
is announced today and I hope you're
excited to hear about a few more things
and the cool things that you can build
on top of Google cloud platform and so
with that I'm gonna jump into it so as I
said I know it's the end of the day I'm
gonna promise to keep it light fun
there's actually even a demo at the end
with a little bit of audience
participation to please stay for that
and let's get started so my name is
Morgan Holman I'm a product manager on
the surplice team within GCP and I can't
wait to tell you about what you can
build using surveillance and events and
so I thanked you a number of times one
for finding it two for coming at the end
of your day and three for attending a
session that actually had a pretty
nebulous title right doing more with
less with less what well here Google we
care a lot about developer productivity
we really want you to be able to do the
most in the shortest amount of time and
add value to your users so we want you
to be able to code with less code less
infrastructure and less work overall and
I'm going to talk to you about service
events and how we make that possible and
so what would what would be your ideal
right if you if you had any system any
framework what would be your ideal
framework it would be one that allows
you to do nothing but focus on your
business logic right to focus on user
value the things that keep users coming
back to your application day in and day
out which is frankly hard enough and
things such as monitoring configuration
service discovery Auto healing rollback
all these you know complicated and
thankless tasks that frankly at times
take teams of people to do their very
very important but they have almost
nothing to do with actually running your
business so ideally you would just focus
on business logic and software is
evolved for this purpose right if you
remember the old days of httpd and
you had this very very thin interface
that literally just lets you receive a
request and send a response and
everything in between you had to do
yourself and over time software evolved
to do a lot more of the heavy lifting
for you right a lot of the modern
frameworks do you just about everything
nowadays right they do routing they do
session management they do caching ORM
so you don't actually have to talk to
the database a lot of the heavy lifting
has been removed when it comes to
writing software and infrastructure has
been on the same trend of evolution
right abstracting away more and more and
more such that you can focus more on
adding user value focus more on business
logic from the early days of self hosted
servers I mean if you've been in the
industry for a while maybe remember the
days where you had a co-worker coworker
or a colleague rung a 10 million dollar
business under their desk right I mean
it was kind of the Wild West but
certainly not the way to build a
resilient reliable a fault-tolerant
business and we then moved to managed
data centers we then moved to coalos we
got more efficiency we moved to VMs
where you pack more onto the machine
itself and then public cloud was a step
function change meaning making it much
much easier to provision infrastructure
much much easier to build systems and
then even on top of public cloud right
we've added a lot of services to make
things even easier on you as a developer
things like App Engine bigquery cloud
storage compute engine datastore
firebase data flow and many other
technologies but there's still a lot of
challenges right I mean it's not it's
not a completely solved problem there's
complexity even a modest internet
business these days let's say you're
doing e-commerce a small e-commerce site
you've probably got a users database
products database a transactions
database you're getting a number of
different API is it's necessarily
complex you've got an efficient
infrastructure many of you and that if
you're running on traditional
infrastructure let's say you have
nothing more than a diurnal pattern to
your usage right now let's say you're a
single geography a single continent when
your users are asleep and not actually
hitting your service you're still
running servers right you're inefficient
and then these systems at times can be
very difficult to it to extend right
it's the corollary of the complexity
point that the more complex the system
every new feature you want to add ends
up being surgery that you do to that
system and so you know it's called doing
more with less service in events you
know I'm going to say that service plus
events helps to solve these problems so
how did you do it
so one it's very simple and I'm gonna
talk more about each one of these points
it's just code you give us your code we
do everything else it's fully managed
again we run your code I we take care of
patching and auto scaling and everything
else you just give us your actual
business logic and we do everything else
and we automatically make connections
between services so you don't need to
think about api's and handshakes and all
that it's efficient and that you pay for
what you use again in that diurnal
example with service when your users are
asleep you're not paying it's
event-driven so again we only spin up
compute when there's actually an event
to process and then finally it's
extensible so the very nature of service
encourages us to write software as micro
services and so adding a new feature
adding new functionality is as simple as
just adding a new micro service to your
overall application and so now let's
talk really briefly about Google's
service event driven framework cloud
functions yes I'm calling it a framework
and that very much like the web and app
frameworks cloud functions is a
framework that sits on top of Google's
infrastructure right that lets you very
simply access a number of services and
just focus on writing your code and so
it's circles what does that mean no
server management you don't even need to
think about service simple deployment
model just give us your code I can't say
that enough times we oughta scale it up
and down and you pay only for what you
use it's event-driven it seems pretty
simple but let me just go through it an
event is admitted if your function is
configured to listen to that particular
event we didn't spin it up your code
executes and so what does this look like
this looks like just focusing on your
business logic right we had all those
things that need to happen to actually
get your code in a place where it could
spin up and run and respond to things on
that very first slider I guess that
second slide but this is where you're
focused just your business logic now and
con function supports events for more
than 20 Google services
so many of the most popular Google
services are already integrated with
cloud functions and we're adding more
all the time and this is really exciting
for us because each new source that we
add ends up unlocking a whole new set of
use cases and you can imagine that the
things you can build with let's say a
cloud build integration or a stack
driver logging integration are quite
different from the things you might
build with a Gmail integration and so
every time you open up on these new
sources developers just amazes some Wow
with the things they build like the you
guys are much more creative than we are
it's a recap why should you do this way
the serval is an event-driven way again
it's simple it's efficient and it's
extensible easily extensible so don't
just take my word for it that's enough
for the theory let's look at an actual
example so in the traditional
development model I'm gonna go to a
situation or scenario that many of you
have probably faced if you've done
anything consumer facing at least you've
probably faced the situation where you
want to allow people to create profiles
or some sort of artifact that they exist
in your system and so if you've got
profiles you probably want to have a
photo associated with that profile so
the user let's say once it upload a
photo and then you want to crop it and
store it down for the profiles page how
would you do that in the traditional
model well you'd probably stand up a
server and use a single server out to do
everything and so the user would upload
the photo around a crop the image and
store down into the profile directory
it's not too bad but now I want to
extend that right I want to resize that
same image and I want to use it for my
user gallery right I've got a number of
images let's say I want to be able to
actually have a gallery and see all the
users that are there how do we do that
well we just add more logic to our
server app right so now we upload the
photo we crop the image we store it in
the storage and profiles we now resize
the photo we store it into the gallery
section roof that was a fair amount of
work but at least we're done but now
let's say I want to index those profile
images for searches all right let's see
some metadata comes in it's the users
name right and you should be able to
search via a name for for some profile
that's on the system
and so what do I do well let's just add
even more logic to that server round
right so upload the image crop it stored
and profiles resize the image stored in
the gallery and now take that metadata
in this case I've shown the the first
name last name in the image URL and
let's write that into search is anyone
starting to feel a little bit like this
woman at the edge of this cliff very
cool picture I don't know how they
ticket looks like she's gonna fall
what's wrong with this model right what
are some of the shortcomings well it's
incredibly complex right there's a lot
going on inside that single round it's
hard to understand because so much is
going on it's hard to debug the
infrastructure is inefficient right we
have a server in the middle to do
nothing but just write things to storage
doesn't really need to be there we have
servers running whether there's traffic
or not and then it's difficult to extend
right every change requires surgery to
the router because we keep adding more
and more and I haven't even talked about
some of the hairy distributed systems
problems associated with failures what
happens you know how do we handle
retries and so is there another way to
do this again the title of this talk is
service plus events you know I'm gonna
get a service event so yes there's
another way but let's look at how the
event-driven model helps to solve this
problem so how would we do this with
cloud functions googles and then driven
service framework well let's say the
user with then upload the file directly
to storage right you don't need a server
there are no servers in this picture
whatsoever that would then cause an
event to fire it's called object final
as the name is unimportant but it's
basically a create event that then
causes a function to trigger which crops
the image and stores it down into
profiles no servers on this page nothing
for you as a developer to operate less
code less infrastructure less work with
cloud functions we really can do or with
less and so let's come back to some of
those advantages I talked about right on
that slide with a simple efficient
extensible let's start with simple so
there's less boilerplate code to write
and then even even in a very very
lightweight web serving framework like
flask here in Python
there's a lot of boilerplate right I've
got an import flask
I've got to decorate my route to tell it
where to send the request I've got a
write a main function action on the app
there's just a lot here that has nothing
to do with the business logic right but
business logic is in is really just in
two lines of code here and for those of
you who actually know something about
deployment right if you're not just
writing the backend code or potentially
deploying it as well you know I've
skipped an entire step which is having
to configure engine X right like how do
I configure my proxy
who here believes that the way they add
superior value to their users is by
configuring nginx better than the
competition right it's somewhat
rhetorical please no one raised their
hand but but but it's true right it's
something we all have to deal with and
it adds almost no user value and to be
clear so you don't feel like I'm beating
up and nginx
I think it's great it's wonderful in
fact we here at Google packaged nginx
into many of our images for our runtimes
but again it's something we should worry
about not something that you as a
developer should worry about you should
just worry about your code and let's
look at what happens when we start
getting this in the service in advanced
way it's just the business logic right
just those two lines of code Google is
your framework Google is your proxy it's
all so simple in the sense that it's
single purpose right so we go from
something like this and I know it's I've
kind of loaded this slide by calling it
the monolith hand handler but we go from
a handler that's doing a lot of
different things right it's cropping an
image it's saving it to storage its
resizing the image saving it to storage
it's indexing the metadata and again I
didn't even talk about retries and
failures right I've shared a pretty
simple case we move from that to this
where everything is single purpose right
we're still doing all the same steps
admittedly right I'm still have to
resize we have to crop it you have to
index things but everything is single
purpose and it's much easier to
understand much easier to debug and oh
you know those distributed systems
problems associated with failures and
retries you know who handles that Google
we retry your code but it fails
and it's also simple in the sense that
we make automatic connections between
services and so this is a point that at
times can get lost but if I want to talk
from service a service B let's say its
cloud storage talking to a cloud
function I don't have to pull I don't
have to check and say did something
change is something new is something
there was something new when most of the
time the answer's no the event is
delivered directly to my service
function there are no API is to contact
I don't need to figure out how to go
talk to the service to go get a piece of
data I don't need to know how to go talk
to a service to configure to talk to
talk to my function all the data that I
need is delivered to my event delivered
directly to my function in most cases
and then finally we broker those
connections and automatically in a sense
that it literally takes about five
seconds in the UI maybe two seconds in
the command line to say a wired function
X up to cloud storage bucket making it
very very simple for you to build
sophisticated powerful systems it's also
very efficient I won't belabor this
point because I think you've heard it
many times but if you have an input that
looks like this something that's kind of
spiky let's say you're a startup company
and you have very few users adding
profiles in the very beginning of your
company's evolution or maybe you're very
mature and people already have the
profiles on their system and let's
pretend that this is not Facebook where
people change their profile every single
day but a normal website where you know
you might change it once a year your
input could very well look like this
with cloud functions your bill would
track the input with the traditional
server dominated model when that servers
up you're paying for it and then it's
also very extensible so let's go back to
that original example right
we were already bursting at the seams
with complexity when we just had three
steps right now let's say I want to add
a fourth let's say I want to actually
extract information out of the image
right I don't want to just take the
metadata that you've provided I want to
see what's going on in the image maybe I
want to make it a visual search and then
I want to index those attributes for
even better searches so how could I do
this well I could just add more logic to
the server right I could upload the
photo crop it and save it resize and
save it and
the metadata run into the vision API and
analyze the the information and index
those tags that's a lot of work it's a
lot of surgery that we have to go do
whereas with the service model the
event-driven model let's say I saved the
original image and I'm triggering these
three function flows right the crop and
save the resize and save the index
metadata I've already got this right
adding a new piece of functionality is
as simple as just adding another action
to the upload event much much simpler
much more extensible no surgery required
and so a recap it's simple it's just
code it's fully managed we automate all
the connections it's efficient you pay
for what you use in its event-driven and
finally it's highly extensible and that
you're basically writing micro services
and so extending it is just as simple as
adding a new Mike reserves so don't take
my word for it let's look at how some
customers are using service plus events
they build very sophisticated systems so
the first customer going to talk about
is smart parking and they're building a
real-time analytics system a little bit
of information on smart parking so
they've been around for over 15 years
they're in Australia New Zealand and the
UK they've got tens of thousands of
sensors in production and they are
powered by Google cloud platform let's
feel a little bit more about what they
do the number of cars using urban roads
is on the rise putting additional strain
on traffic infrastructure finding a safe
and convenient place to park your car
also adds to the frustration of planning
a journey we have a solution for this in
our smart park system the beauty of
smart Park lies in its simplicity and
agility allowing us to configure each
site to any set of requirements
first we survey and assess which of our
technologies is most suitable to record
vehicle activity this could be automatic
number plate recognition variable
message signs car counters in ground or
overhead sensors or a mix of all the
above these sensing devices are designs
of relay live parking events to our
smart spot units which provide gateways
for the data and act as zones of
compatibility for other services let me
introduce you to the brains behind our
system we call it smart cloud and it's a
powerful and intuitive two-way
communication platform that processes
millions of events each day first smart
cloud in takes the data from the smart
spot gateways it then processes each
action and sends real-time information
around guidance and availability to
display such as our mobile app overhead
occupancy indicators and guidance
signage so I know a lot of you came in
from different locales and but if your
city looks anything like San Francisco I
know you're probably asking one question
after seeing that video when is this
coming to my city very very interesting
solution the dense and wonderful things
so what are some of the challenges
associated with building a real-time
data analytics system one you need
up-to-the-minute sometimes even up to
the second freshness you can imagine
that having steel data if you're the
operator of a parking lot or a parking
garage can be a huge problem right if
there's an event going on since it's a
ball game or concert being stealing by
even as much as 10 minutes could show a
very very different picture to the data
is coming from a disparate set of
sources as you saw in the video they've
gotten in ground sensors they get
overhead sensors they've got plate
readers
they've got car counters many different
sensors providing data into the system
and so as a result what do you have to
do you've got to normalize that data
you've got to transform that data and
then finally you get aggregated so a lot
of data manipulation that smart parking
has to do and how are they doing it well
with this architecture here
so this is their SmartCloud architecture
and you can see they have a number of
devices that are sending information
from the different parking spots they've
got their smart spots which do a little
bit of aggregation of just the raw data
and then the backbone of this system is
really Google IOT core it's taking it
all the data and piping that into GCP
through pumps up at which point it then
enters two different data flows so one
is the event flow where the raw data is
simply being piped in and saved into
persistent storage if you notice this
whole thing is serviced there's no
infrastructure to operate and then
there's the data flow and it's almost
interpretations a inappropriately named
but poorly named or unfortunately named
because we have a product called data
flow that sits in the data flow but try
not to be confused bottom line what it's
doing there is it's running through a
number of different analytic systems so
bigquery Cloud ml data lab sorry vision
data lab ml and it's analyzing the data
adding insights to the data and then
also saving it into persistent storage
at that point there api's that digests
the data and send that data to different
clients you've got dashboards so this is
the car offer in the parking garage
operator they can see real-time what's
going on payments if you're making a
payment keeping that data accurate
signage so you know how many spots are
available or free in a particular area
our favorite enforcement here yes they
are helping folks to know when you have
overstayed your welcome in a particular
parking spot and then finally there's a
metrics pipeline for folks internal in
the company to understand how the
network is performing and perhaps even
troubleshoot some issues so all of this
done without operating any
infrastructure and don't take my word
for word listen to their CTO in fact
he's here at GCP next you'll recognize
him from that wonderful beard that he's
got if you see him tell him I said hi
but just listen to the efficiency in the
productivity that he has gotten out of
operating a service event-driven
infrastructure they were able to
completely reaaargh attack their
platform something that took them 12
years to build in less than 18 months
using shirtles that allowed them to then
expand
their business globally also cloud
functions are services event-driven
framework was the foundation for their
smart cloud data intelligence platform
and it provides their customers with
instant to the second accurate data
intelligence and scale for millions of
transactions each day so very
sophisticated very powerful system
operating absolutely no infrastructure
so let's switch gears a little bit this
is the last customer example I have but
- something that's completely different
to building a mobile application so I
want to tell you about how development
firm Posse used service and events to
build the Hamilton a little bit more
about that Hamilton is one the most
talked about in best-loved musicals with
shows on Broadway in London and around
the country we wanted something to make
the show more accessible for our fans so
we wanted to develop an app to meet the
needs of fans as we started to expand
the brand we turn to a posse a newer
face development firm to help us develop
an economic Hamilton's flutter app
launched in the app store in the Play
Store three months after we wrote our
first line of code and we accomplished a
time
fans can enter a daily lottery for a
shot at $10 tickets buy merchandise from
e-commerce experience take selfie photos
with a ham can and get daily news
nothing so very cool Hamilton is doing
exceptionally well on Broadway and it's
pretty exciting that they build there
are their their app on our
infrastructure so it's completely built
on serverless plus events it's got a
number of pieces of functionality
they've got a lottery we're gonna talk a
little bit more about that later they
got karaoke trivia and the ham cam the
selfie app and you can buy merchandise
from within the end as well so let's
talk about the lottery so for those of
you who aren't familiar the lottery you
know Hamilton is extraordinarily popular
the lottery is an opportunity to not pay
the entry price which I believe is
around $200 but the reality is that
these things sell out so it's probably
more like 800 or $1000 but instead be
ten dollars to enter a lottery I'm gonna
chance it at tickets these are great
tickets I think maybe 40 or so per show
sign up for the lottery two days
beforehand
a day beforehand
the drawing happens and you're either
selected as a winner or you're told to
into the lottery on the subsequent day
and it's you know it's really
interesting and I love making developers
lives better and I love making you more
productive but I also love and I hate to
use the trite line in fact I won't use a
trite line making the world a better
place but we're making the world a
better place in the sense that the
creators of Hamilton with this lottery
have allowed a whole new demographic to
actually access Hamilton and it's
interesting because they're all about
flipping models on their head the whole
play itself is about it's in a
majority-minority cast portraying the
life and times of Alexander Hamilton and
this lottery as I said kinda does the
same thing for for the demographics of
the audiences so how they're doing that
so a user says I want to be formal
lottery enter me that request then gets
written to the real-time database which
is the backing store for all of the
Hamilton app it then triggers a cloud
function which first goes through
firebase off to say that this is a
legitimate request that function then
registers the fact that the user has
chosen to enter the particular lottery
there's a cron job but then operates
down here on a daily basis triggering a
cloud function that says who's won on
that particular day it selects the
winners writes it back into the
real-time database and also notifies
lucky seat that these people have won
print their tickets and the users are
told of their winning status or to enter
the lottery the next day really
interesting feature next feature the ham
cam the selfie app so this is a pretty
simple feature but again it's completely
service completely event-driven users
basically take a photo take a selfie in
the app it then writes directly to cloud
storage it's actually a lot like our
theoretical example that we went through
mediated by fired us off just to make
sure that this is a legitimate request
that then kicks off the cloud function
which crops and resizes the image then
writes that image URL back to the
real-time database so that the user
knows he's there
wonderful selfie in the app and posse
told us that we made it so easy for them
with the real-time database with cloud
functions with
found storage to build this feature that
instead of operating infrastructure they
could spend much more time I'm just
making it fun making it interesting and
adding effects like this to the app and
then finally last example I'll show you
from Hamilton is merchandising right
just buying merchandise in the store so
the user says I want to buy something
that then kicks off to different club
functions the first contacts that the
Magento API which is an API for managing
e-commerce stores things like SKU
management pricing inventory management
all done via functions the next function
then contacts stripe to make payments
and this is a really interesting
application kind of a perfect
application of service in this sense and
that stripe doesn't trust mobile clients
doesn't trust desktop clients to make
transactions so it requires you to have
a private API key that sits on a server
so if you're a very large site that does
you know tons and tons of transactions
per day maybe this is a non-issue but if
you're an app like Hamilton where most
of its about consuming content and not
really about buying merchandise then
having that infrastructure operating
that infrastructure is quite the burden
cloud functions allows you to do that
server key without operating any
infrastructure whatsoever so a perfect
application of service alright so those
are just a couple examples of what
customers are doing with service with
events to build very sophisticated
systems and now I want to show you
something that we can build very simply
using shortlist and events so we're
going to come back to that example I
showed earlier the gallery happen so we
have a gallery it is backed by a cloud
fire store that just went beta today
hopefully you all saw that it's a an
infinitely scalable no sequel database
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
upload photo it's gonna hit Twilio we're
then gonna save that down to storage
into profiles
we're then gonna index the data
basically take the name that was entered
in and the image URL put that in the
cloud fire store which date are our
gallery and then that will kick off
another function that then analyzes the
image pulls out and extracts the visual
information
via the vision API right sit back into
fire stores sorry my pointer is dying
and then updates the gallery in real
time and so with that see let's switch
to the demo please all right so here's
our gallery app and you can see I'm in
the interest of making it easy to
understand what's going on you can see I
have both the name of the person who's
uploaded something and the tags on it so
we can search here it's a visual search
engine so no Connor put a dog in so see
that image we can search on things in
the image content itself like sky
mountain bike in spell lake so you see
we have a visual search engine right
here you know I'm giving giving Google
search a run for its money funny enough
this actually doesn't look that
different from the original version of
Google so anyway let's now add an image
to this gallery so I'm gonna upload I'm
gonna walk you through what's going on
behind the scenes but I'm gonna upload
an image actually of my daughter so
upload that
okay let's see hopefully connectivity is
good enough here that goes through and
so I'm going to show you one it's
completely surplice so I got firestorm
running right here that's our backing
store I've got a number of functions so
this is the SMS function that talks to
Twilio this is a function that then
writes the data into storage this is the
function that takes that that data and
storage and extracts the tags writes it
into fire store and this is the function
that adds vision tags to our app I'm
going to just show you very quickly how
that flows through our system alright so
we can see the very first function so
scent okay yep name is easy that's our
daughter's name and the image was sent
there next step let's see if that
completed this is saving down to storage
yep success next step writing a fire
store Wow lot of stuff there okay
success right there and then final step
is actually running the vision API and
we can see you can see all the tags that
come through so person facial smile
child girl emotion sitting standing fun
laughter all added as tags to our image
and now if I look
oh well I've got two copies there of my
daughter I hope that's not a demo bug
but rather the fact that I have loaded
it twice we know so now I can search on
that search on girl role that shows up
as well
so that's our app and so can we switch
back to the presentation really quickly
and so now I'm gonna do something
potentially risky audience participant
participation now it's your turn
so text an image with a name all in the
same text it can be a picture of you
you'd be a picture of your kid I put
mine up there your dog or anything if
you a flower but text me an image as I
said it's a little dangerous and put it
in our gallery I'm trusting you okay
let's see we am so you have any news guy
we've got a lot of stuff now all right
the images here all right we got
Tomatoes this lets this is cool oh
another let's see let's teach child
imaginable look at that like all those
kids cute kids and I don't know why we
have to it my daughter not sure just
putting kid man all right how about fun
all right okay kids are having fun car
look at that some cool images so I don't
know if you notice but as I said I
trusted you folks but I didn't show the
in the code but I've also got safesearch
running and so Dan I made a mistake in
trusting you apparently to be clear I
you know tuned this actually I decided
to be very conservative because I knew
someone would upload something so it's
actually very possible this is just a
picture of a family vacation and Dan has
a shirt off very possible it's totally
innocuous Linus same thing this one I
had to clean the word here so not sure
that's so innocuous but anyway you can
see that we've built a pretty
sophisticated system and I'm operating
zero infrastructure here it's all being
done because journalists via events can
we jump back to the presentation please
alright and so with that I wanted to
recap in Service Plus events increases
developer productivity you can build
more powerful systems with less code
less infrastructure and less work it's
simpler it's more efficient and allows
you to build more extensible systems
there are ton of event sources available
on GCP to trigger our service framework
cloud functions and we're adding more
all the time customers are using it and
they're building real systems they're
building powerful systems using service
events and frankly you can too so here a
few others shirtless talks companies
have actually already happened there few
tomorrow as well if you're really
interested in service please go to those
and with that that's it again thank you
so much I really appreciate your coming
for this talk especially at the end of
the day now go forth and enjoy your
evenings
[Applause]
[Music]